I'm sorry I was late I was just
backstage trying to convince Jennifer
Lopez that the best way to remove
double-faced tape is with saliva
and wasn't it great to see Sean Connery
so many people here tonight so many
people here tonight are wearing Armani
but Sean was wearing Red Lobster and I
think that's really nice you know they
always get a beautiful young woman to
present the awards to the Science and
Technology people its Hollywood's way of
taunting them with something they will
never have and here is the star of How
to Lose a Guy in 10 days Kate Hudson
each year at a lavish dinner party the
Academy presents their scientific and
technical awards to the inventors of
additional tools of the cinema trade
this year it was my pleasure to read the
names of those whose hard work makes all
movie makers work easier not easy just
easier here's a sip of the fun we had at
the Regent Beverly Wilshire hotel three
weeks ago the first Oscar of the evening
was awarded to alias wavefront for the
development of a 3d animation software
package called Maya is with great pride
that we accept this Oscar on behalf of
the many talented individuals that alias
wavefront past and present were honored
were humbled and we are absolutely
pumped the second oscar was awarded to
two competitors aryan Panavision after a
gracious handshake and deciding who
spoke first here's with the two largest
motion picture camera manufacturers had
to say thank you at the Academy for this
really really great honor I would like
to thank the Academy and just say how
proud and honored we have Panavision art
to be here